the raiders get back at it sunday at
allegiant ron futrell telling us revenge
could be in the minds of the raiders
this weekend
well hi everybody the raiders will try
to keep their record perfect this sunday
against the miami dolphins already the
raiders have wins over two afc playoff
teams the ravens and the steelers they
try to make it three in a row against
the dolphins on sunday the dolphins beat
the raiders in a strange game last
december late in the game very late in
the game ryan fitzpatrick leads the
dolphins downfield there's that face
mask call right there then the raiders
give up a long field goal the finns get
a one point win now this season the
dolphins are struggling on offense but
their defense is one of the best in the
league i mean they're really a good
defense they have great corners that can
handle the the one-on-one burden the
pressure
of covering a guy with no help for a
long time howard and jones are two of
the best in the league
now the dolphins will be without their
top quarterback to a tonga vialoa he
injured his ribs last week jacoby
bessette will start in his place as for
the raiders there were questions about
derek carr's ankle early in the week
he's fine and will start on sunday with
the raiders i'm ron futrell reporting
live local now